in new york while we have been speaking
the un human rights council has voted to
suspend russia who was a permanent
member of that human rights council to
suspend their membership so russia are
now no longer
a member of the human rights council of
the united nations because of those
reports coming out of your country about
what is happening there and to you i'm
sure it is a symbolic gesture in terms
of this war is still going on in your
country but if i could just get your
reaction to that move by the un
first of all definitely we are welcome
there
secondly this is next
should be done
to suspend the russian federation in
united nations
this is
repeat once again the
case which is happening in
1939 when the
soviet union under the stalin after
attack on finland was suspended in
league of nations
and with this situation after butcher
after all the massacre happened in
ukraine
no neither putin
no russian government
even no russian people because this was
done not
directly by putin this was done by the
russian soldiers
they have no right even to
to to say
human rights
and with this situation i think we are
very much welcome we are close this is
the justice who happened now in the
council of human rights of united
nations bravo
petro poroshenko former president of
ukraine thank you so much for your time
here on sky news reacting there live to
the news that russia has been expelled
from the un council
on human rights let's bring in our
washington correspondent mark stone
who's been watching the proceedings
unfold live in new york um mark not an
unexpected move but a very
significant one
a significant move a dramatic move a
move that hasn't happened uh for for
quite some time the last country to be
kicked out of the human rights council
was libya back in 2011 but of course
libya is not a country of the same
statute as russia it's not a permanent
member of the security council but
voting in favor of this decision to kick
russia off the human rights council 93
countries voting against 24
abstentions 58 now the abstentions don't
count towards the two-thirds majority uh
two-third majority of those that voted
either yes or no was about what i think
78
and so um with 93 voting yes
that means that this resolution is
adopted
russia is now no longer a member of the
un human rights council
mark stone a correspondent in washington
thank you that breaking news russia has
been suspended has been expelled rather
from the un human rights council uh that
vote taking place in new york we'll have
reaction to that uh throughout the
evening here on the sky news a
significant move